virtual reality had this boom in the 90s
I mean first off we were interacting
with computers in an all-new way we have
graphical interfaces computers were
network the rise of the internet had
happened and you also started seeing a
lot of companies trying to bring virtual
reality headsets to a consumer market a
lot of them launched and all of them
failed and that's where palmer luckey
comes in with an invention called the
oculus rift so I picked up a lot of old
gear from a variety of places that I
started to reverse engineer and I
learned a lot from those I learned
mostly what not to do for virtual
reality of work you need immersion and
that comes from having a field of vision
that's wide enough that you see a world
that wraps around you this is only
worthwhile if you have a wide field to
be if you don't have that it's just a
television on your head of course the
more that virtual world wraps around you
the more important it's going to be for
it to move immediately and exactly to
reflect the motion of your head if it
doesn't it leads to something that's
called simulator sickness and the
culprit is something called latency in
the past people are saying you know if
you can get to under a hundred
milliseconds and the users not going to
be able to notice but we're finding that
people are sensitive down to 20
milliseconds and even lower than that in
some situations so how do you cut down
latency well first you have to track the
head and you have to track it a lot the
thing we're really looking for was a
high data rate high sampling rate the
faster you're getting your measurements
in the less time there is between the
actual movement and the reflection of
that to the display in the virtual
reality headset today we're actually
close to 20 milliseconds and day so the
rift it's a game peripheral right you're
going to use it to play games I'm just
going to blow your mind but it also has
a lot of promise for education for
productivity for cinema what excites me
about the future it's taking this
hopefully polished and rock-solid thing
shipping it out and seeing the amazing
things that people build this has been
the best time for VR in a very long time
there's been more virtual reality
software created in the last year than
in the last 20 years combined so if one
thing's clear it's this three years ago
we thought VR was
dad looks like it's back to life